il y avait un contrôle de l'information
une censure l'histoire les a oubliés
pendant des années le 17 octobre 1961 en
pleine guerre d'algérie quarante mille
algériens protestent à paris contre le
couvre feu qui leur est imposé par
maurice papon alors préfet de police de
paris la manifestation est violemment
réprimée par les forces de l'ordre
gilles manceron historien revient sur
ces images marquantes je les avais vus à
la télévision effectivement elles ont
été diffusées avec un commentaire
attribuant les violences à des à des
heurts entre policiers et fln parlant de
tir dont les policiers ont fait l'objet
ce qui est inexact ce qui est un
vraiment une cep news officielles si je
puis dire seuls ses archives vidéos et
photos témoignent de l'événement côté
politique c'est silence radio et la
presse est censuré on ne voit pas les
violences exercées contre eux à ce
moment là on voit simplement que on les
leur demande de mettre les mains en
l'air et on les fait monter dans les
cars de la ratp qui ont été
réquisitionnés pour aller dans les
centres de rétention
qu'ils avaient préparés aussi au palais
des sports et à dans le bois de
vincennes au centre de tri qui
correspond à la cartoucherie de
vincennes actuellement il faut attendre
1985 pour que la télé parle de ce 17
octobre 1961 à l'origine de cette
médiatisation l'association sos racisme
écoutez le témoignage de cet algérien
présent 1961 on avait il est décédé qui
a essayé de france hier
le barrage de police mme police de crs
et ses terres et il a été foudroyé à
coups de mitraillette sur sur le jean
mailhot j'aime sur le champ sur le pont
de neuilly c'est un événement dont on
n'a pas parlé pendant plus de 20 ans et
dans les années 80 à la faveur de
l'alternance politique
des années 80 et bien
l'information est un peu plus relâchée
permet des interstices autre témoignage
celui d'yvon quan chef de police en 1961
voici sa version des faits toujours en
nous avons entendu des coups de feu à
l'arrière des manifestations mais en
aucun cas ni mes hommes ni l'égard
de leurs armes ce soir-là ce monsieur
répète la version mensongère
sur le pont de neuilly nous n'avons pas
tiré
les algériens ont tiré ce qui est faux
et lui qui faisait partie de la spa ils
ont avec leurs armes automatiques
mitraillé une foule qui descendait de
nanterre de puteaux de suresnes le 17
octobre 2001 quarante ans après les
faits une plaque commémorative a été
posée par bertrand de la noue est alors
maire de paris
en 2012 par le biais d'un communiqué le
président françois hollande
reconnaissait avec lucidité les faits
[Musique]